hey guys listen I wanted to talk about
stress and your immune system the
connection between the two now it is
true that there's a lot of your immune
system rather to your gut and its
influence on the integrity of the lining
of the colon and and what you eat okay
but what I'm going to talk about is
another thing I'm going to talk about
how stress influences your immune system
in general because if you take any
person with a chronic health problem
nearly a hundred percent the time it
originated with some type of a stressful
event I did my live show last Friday and
I had a lady call in and talk about
health problems in chronic health
problems she had digestive problems and
allergies and sleep problems and she
didn't have a way problem but she had
all sorts of digestive issues and this
has been going on for years and years
and years and she was eating better but
it wasn't getting well so I asked her I
said when exactly did it all start okay
she couldn't really remember so I I said
well when were you doing well and she
gave me a date I think it was like a
when she was 30 years old and then 31
that's when things started going
downhill and I wanted to find out what
was the change what happened and she
told me a massive stress situation which
I already knew because I've been doing
this for 29 years and this is what comes
up over and over and over it's this
underlying stress thing so what I want
to talk about is how stress can
predispose you to getting sick okay
because what it does to the adrenal
hormone called cortisol cortisol is a
type of hormone that is intimately
involved in the immune response it
actually suppresses the white blood cell
it suppresses the t-cells for example
which are involved in training the
immune system and getting them to learn
how to fight off infections it actually
lowers the immune barrier then allows
the viruses to innervate the cells
that's why people get virus infections
when they get stressed shingles herpes
things like that it actually will
increase the platelets which then can
set you up for clotting factors okay
increases neutrophils which then lead to
inflammation so there's a whole immune
thing going on when that stress is
activated in fact take any autoimmune
disease and stress is definitely
involved in those conditions think about
the typical treatment is prednisone what
is that it's a synthetic type of
cortisol because the adrenal hormones
will decrease inflammation and decrease
immune function and so if there's an
allergy involved or high levels of
histamine people take prednisone or
cortisone okay because it has that
function so basically when the stress
goes to high we have an alteration in
course all and adrenal function and this
leads to a drop in the defense mechanism
now there's many different types of
stress you have physical trauma you have
surgery you have being involved in a
relationship with someone who is
stressing you out 24/7 but I think the
biggest stress is
losses okay a loss of a loved one loss
of a job that can really hit somewhat
hard core and that's the health - starts
going downhill and of course there's all
sorts of things that you can do you know
go for long walks being sunshine to get
more vitamin D which is all gonna help
the immune system you know remove
yourself from the stress go on a
vacation take B vitamins get more sleep
and of course you already know this but
what I want to talk about is what to do
with the stress that's stuck in your
body you have to realize that all the
stress that you experience kind of gets
stuck in the body like a sponge thus
saying that time heals all no it doesn't
it actually makes things get worse we're
letting to stress because all the stress
tends to build up in certain parts of
your body so there is a way to help
someone with the accumulation of stress
and I developed an acupressure technique
I've put some links down below of all
the different techniques that you can
use there's different parts of your body
that are involved in the flight or fight
mechanism that's called a sympathetic
nervous system and then there's also the
opposite system called the
parasympathetic switch counter the
stress and this is part of the nervous
system that is throughout the body so
there is a way to tap into that too
least that stress the one of the most
powerful ones is working on the neck
points because up in the top part of the
neck there is certain center that
controls the parasympathetic nervous
system this is kind of like the off
switch this is the system that relaxes
you
so I found when you apply pressure to
these points it can really help people
get into a relaxed State the next points
are in the mid-back okay these are part
of the sympathetic nervous system points
which can also be released to relax the
flight or fight mechanism then you have
points in the abdomen area which can
indirectly influence the actual adrenal
glands which are located deep inside now
you're not actually working on the
adrenal glands you're working on the
acupressure points that are connected to
the adrenal gland you take any person
that's stressed out they're bound to
have a lot of tension in the abdomen and
the muscles around the adrenal glands
now this technique can be done two ways
you can do it on someone else or you can
use a massage tool to do it on yourself
okay I show you both ways
on the video so if you don't have
someone you can get the tool and do it
on yourself alright so I put some links
down below definitely try this out I
think it can really help you especially
if you've been a pin cushion for stress
your entire life
hey you know what I just want to say
something only thirty percent of the
people that watching this video actually
make it this far and you did so I really
appreciate you thank you so much